I think for every action there is an
equal and opposite reaction and I think
at the same time that we have blogs that
run celebrity nuggets like a TMZ i call
it potato chips okay you know we consume
it during the day and we sort of click
on the TMZ we have something like the
big thing that goes a little more in
depth and is a little wiser and I think
there's always going to be that
dichotomy there's going to be some
people who just want time for a potato
chip there are some people who want to
consume a meal and I think the Obama
phenomena is great it's obviously more
than a phenomena but at the same time I
think something like twenty three
percent of people still think he's a
Muslim so not everybody is an
intellectual heavyweight and I promise
you the first time a celebrity gets a
DUI or doesn't wear panties or shaves
their head again it's going to be all
over the news don't think it's going
away we're just in a quiet period okay
you